Welcome to Rubin Select!
What an incredible run we’ve
been since the creation of our own independent
production company just two years ago.
Before I do anything else, I want to give
a huge thanks to all of you who have supported
us from the beginning, as well everyone who
joined along the way.
We’ve truly been on this journey together,
and it’s been an incredible adventure.
You’ve enabled us to build a show and company
that I couldn’t be prouder of --- you’ve
helped us build our home studio, purchase
top of the line equipment, hire more great
team members, take the show on the road, and
so much more.
Thanks to you, we’ve not only survived YouTube
demonetization, but I’ve also been able
to say no to joining other networks, or taking
deals that weren’t the right fit.
Keeping our independence has allowed us to
have the real conversations that I believe
can help heal the divide in this country and
in the world.
But these conversations we foster are only
one part of the solution, and now it’s time
to kick it up a notch.
It’s time to build real community around
the conversations we’re having here on The
Rubin Report.
After emailing, chatting with, and meeting
so many of you, I’m completely convinced
our next steps in this adventure is to build
a home where you can not only listen to us,
but where others can listen to you was well.
Social media can be great, but it’s really
not the place for honest, thoughtful dialogue.
So we’re going to build something on Patreon
that can get you more involved directly with
us, as well as each other, all while getting
away from the outrage machine.
Think of it as a sane space instead of safe
space.
Patreon will be our place to connect with
you, and most importantly, for you to connect
with each other.
Here, you’ll you be able to share comments,
critiques, and opinions with other people
who are just as engaged in these ideas as
you are.
We will build an ideologically diverse community
of free thinkers from around the world, all
in one place...That’s where Rubin Select
comes in.
This will be our home base for all things
Rubin Report, powered by the very people who
support the show...you.
This is your direct link to me -- myself and
my team will be in the comments and conversations,
ready to interact with you as you interact
with each other.
Plus, if you join, you’ll get some cool
perks such as behind the scenes footage, bonus
clips, livestreams, chats, and much more.
As we grow, our goal stays the same: having
honest, unfiltered long form discussions with
people from every walk of life, some of whom
I agree with and some of whom I disagree with.
This thing has gone from a little YouTube
channel to something that is actually moving
the dial of the national conversation.
As our influence grows, so does our ability
to really affect change, and I want you to
be as much part of it as I am.
As our community builds, we’ll be able to
expand the team, produce more content, and
introduce you to more people and ideas which
will give you the tools fight for what you
believe in.
Level up in the conversation by joining Rubin
Select now and let’s continue this adventure
together.